[Musique]
elles sont aussi belles vues du ciel
qu'au fond de l'eau
les maldives
1200 il est une barrière de corail parmi
les plus riches de la planète
sur près de 2000 km elle offre aux
poissons et autres animaux marins un
lieu de vie indispensable
mais cette oasis de corail est
aujourd'hui en danger
allez c'est parti pour comprendre
l'ampleur de la menace il faut suivre à
sanaa remède
ce passionné de plongée a vu ces
dernières années mourir sous ses yeux
plus de la moitié du corail qui entoure
l'île où il vit aujourd'hui
on peut voir qu'un corail est mort quand
il n'y a pas de couleur sur celui ci
quand vous vous approchez vous voyez
qu'il n'y a pas eu de vie animale autour
de lui les algues recouvre tout et le
corail ressemble à de la roche
sur cette parcelle du récif maldivien le
constat est flagrant les coraux vivants
ont disparu les fonds marins ressemblent
un désert de sables et de roches
c'est la conséquence des chantiers de
construction qui se développe dans
l'atoll mais aussi du réchauffement des
eaux en 2016 le phénomène climatique el
niño a eu des effets dramatiques
la température de l'eau a été au delà de
ce que les coraux peuvent supporter donc
à cause du réchauffement des eaux les
ports ont blanchi au total aux maldives
en 2016 60% du corail a été endommagé
par el niño
parce que les scientifiques craignent
que le phénomène ne se reproduise à
saint armel anticipe tu peux me passer
l'outil avec l'association qu'il a créée
il étudie une nouvelle méthode de
sauvegarde du corail à partir de ces
fragments en bonne santé qui l'a découpé
qu'il colle sur ces briques il espère
créer une nouvelle colony vous voyez on
a gardé de l'espace entre ses morceaux
ce qu'on espère c'est qu'en grandissant
ces morceaux fusionnent ils grandiront
en même temps et cela donnera un gros
corail
si la méthode fonctionne à sanaa remède
compte la réplique et pour redonner vie
aux coraux
à quelques kilomètres de là une autre
technique a déjà porté ses fruits
tu es prête on y va un méli carreaux
originaire de bayonne est biologiste
marin elle mène ici pour une fondation
un programme de reproduction des coraux
sur le récif d'une île hôtel
est un des meilleurs pays au monde s'est
réuni convoi de la vie sous marine
unique l'an dernier elle a déposé sous
co2 sont structure métallique sur
lesquels étaient attachés de gros
morceaux de corps au de différentes
espèces
depuis ils ont grandi et dans cette
pépinière la vie marine est revenu tout
les cocons à planter ils sont en bonne
santé
vraiment on voit qu'ils ont grandi on
voit qu'il ya des poissons qui sont
arrivés et vraiment on voit que ça a eu
un impact positif sur le récif les
maldives compte encore 250 espèces de
coraux différents pour cette femme leur
sauvegarde doit devenir l' affaire de
tous
vous êtes prêts pour la plongée sous
nassim a été la première femme du pays à
obtenir son diplôme de plongée
aujourd'hui elle offre gratuitement des
cours aux enfants de l'archipel pour les
sensibiliser sur la protection du corail
tu ne peux pas protéger quelque chose
c'est qu'il n'aime pas
il faut tomber amoureux du récif et des
océans pour ensuite vous voir faire des
efforts pour le préserver
sous l'eau pour marquer les esprits
zones 1 à 6 m'emmène les enfants sur un
récif endommagée pour qu'ils constatent
par eux mêmes la disparition du corail
j'ai l'impression que les poissons
perdre leur maison et moins il ya de
poissons - au sens est beau c'est pour
ça que je suis triste quand je vois
qu'on perd du corail
au-delà de l'enjeu environnemental à la
protection du corail est une question de
survie pour les maldives car le récif
corallien protège de la montée des eaux
or le pays est menacé ici 80% des terres
se situent à moins d'un mètre au dessus
du niveau de la mer